qu'est-ce qu'on est
Corti moi Corti toi Thierry HUG moi pas
vouloir fumer qu'allumer de la paix avec
toi toi faire tes saloperie tout seul ça
être beaucoup meilleur pour la santé poo
le chat
ah
[Musique]
moi vouloir être chat ma contre tes B je
me ferai
angora pour me blottir dans tes
bras je te jure je boirai plus que du
lait je n'aime plus la
moi vouloir être
ch moi vouloir être chat retrouver sur
lesr toujours rester à
toi
moi vouloir être ch et ne risquer de tes
doigts
[Musique]
que
moi vouloir être chat comme dehor il
fait froid attendre mon
repas tappuie au creux de tes
dras si un jour tu
préfères ah mais fine caresse les
canines d'un chien en laisse tu le
compte pas sur moi pour dormir sur le
sofa je te montre de quoi est capable un
gros chat à ce jeu là je suis roi et la
souris ce sera
toi et la sour ce sera
toi Laour
ser
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inard tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu